Coach, our flight to Mexico City
doesn’t leave for another 10 hours!
Hey, you gotta be prepared for everything
I DID IT AGAIN
I DIDN’T LEAVE ENOUGH TIME
GO. GO. GO.
HURRY
WOW, NO TRAFFIC!!!!
Let’s practice the Spanish I made you all learn
Dónde esta la end zone?
Aqui esta la end zone
LEAVE ALL YOUR STUFF
WE’LL GET MORE KANSAS CITY
BARBECUE IN MEXICO
Yo, I hope it’s cool
but I have like 20 carry-ons
I’m detecting a lot of weapons
HEY EVERYBODY, THE CHIEFS ARE HERE!
I think we have two potentially explosive offenses
RPO! RPO!
ATTENTION
THE GAME IN MEXICO CITY
THE FLIGHT IS LEAVING RIGHT NOW
Better hurry
I think I have a game script for this somewhere
I have the perfect play
Oh God, they’re both so innovative
Hey man, we’re the same!
We’re both front-runners!
I am very clearly in front of you
We made it!
HELL YEAH! LET’S GO!
Come on, Travis, get on the plane
MAN, TRAVELING IS SO STRESS-FREE
LOOK AT ALL THIS LEG ROOM!
MY DEFENSE!
Always an afterthought